okay get my camera out I'm in selfie
mode just a butt all right go for it and
bang yes look at you
Thank You flyweight
I can check it out I got the sweet
GameSpot logo on my chairs awesome yeah
you know I did have it last week and I
will say I I've got it tattooed on my
very body oh man
like on in the skin that is super yeah
go straight into my heart
it makes my look like a pile of crap
Ezra that I read interestingly isn't
actually reading it's blood yeah my own
but whoa who was that and speaking of
blood that was a deer you know said it's
so glorious I think we should show off
my tattoo on your rubbish shirt by
taking some selfies yes selfies or so
but it can may be extreme even more than
last time more extreme the last time
extreme selfies pot whoo let's do it
um I would like you to jump down onto my
helicopter there and I'm gonna selfie
you falling smoothly between the blades
extreme blade dodging yes exactly what
it is I'm in already wait you go
I did I did learn directly between the
blade that was great jump jump jump come
on you're in it you're in it I think I
snapped to bed early oh the rains coming
down sir the rains come to wash away the
blood from the street whose blood is it
I don't know I think it's mine this guy
knows what's up he's like don't do it
man you've done it like three times
would you remember what just happened
Jesus you got lucky really hey come on
go jumping yes little splatter of blood
Oh excellent you ready for the last one
the last one on this bridge set but
promised last time I can really do this
I'm ready I'm ready I'm I'm getting out
the helicopter today booting up the
camera okay
selfie job jumped up jumping jumping
jumping coming now y'all yes it's so
good oh wow you just like chilling it in
midair right now and what if I what if I
try to cycle this bike
in whoo I can make for good selfie yeah
well I'm just down here my helicopters
so uh I'll give the go-ahead okay so you
ready set
okay well I think I might wait a little
bit oh wow he wasn't stopping all right
getting at the helicopter maybe go now
yeah I know
looks like you're okay riding on my
helicopter my job's so easy in
helicopter star engine a helicopter take
selfie Oh God
hooked into the rotor blades oh I'm so
sorry
go for it extreme bike retrieval oh god
I took it too early I did capture the
last moments of your life though
romantic really yeah play that one at my
funeral please and this was the end of
said yes fly away her look renewed at
that last truck this one here and I want
to get the selfie of eight of a wave of
fires gonna be so good gonna get the
shot now we want to get one shot at this
set yeah the pin is pulled said yeah
yeah yep
it's throw any thrown okay I didn't go
I'm throwing more and more so more here
it comes
more I got the wave I know I just talked
to grenade out my feet quick run in the
helicopter quickly I've got like three
stars only three stars put your phone
away man and get the [ __ ] helicopter
all the helicopters broken I don't think
he'll come to work so it's on fire in
the car in the car everything else blew
up except my car
that's brilliant it was a mistake good
driving I was a mistake good driving
Oh Oh excellent use of driving okay
we're gonna die no we're not no we're
not I'm gonna throw a grenade and it's
gonna save us okay selfie this selfie
I'm gonna get in selfie all right
Oh God Oh they wouldn't let me selfie Oh
bastards you near me said I spawned in a
bush
I get this car there yep stopped it ow I
might have stopped my car so I didn't
die it's great I think just go
cross-country at this point right the
way Bowl there no my cross-country
skills pay many a cross-country bill
hair field all right I'll take the plane
you take the chopped ER we'll go to the
beach let's go one beach please all
right see pals here the beach well I was
looking at you Oh
you